madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
difficile de parler en dernier sans
redondance mon intervention portera donc
sur un point très précis présent projet
de loi mais ô combien important comme
tous les textes d'adaptation au droit de
l'union européenne
celui qui nous est soumis aujourd'hui
embrasse un large champ et au milieu de
tout ça on trouve de l'article 24
un ovni objet législatif non identifié
si vous me permettez l'expression cet
article est aussi lapidaire qui est
satisfaisant
sa clarté est inversement
proportionnelle à l'importance de son
enjeu cet enjeu quel est il
en juin dernier dans le cadre du plexi
leur excite le gouvernement a demandé à
eurotunnel comme au port maritime de
construire des infrastructures destinées
à accueillir des services des contrôles
douaniers et sanitaires aux frontières
en effet le royaume uni devenant pays
tiers par rapport à dieu il fallait
rétablir ses contrôles qui se traduisait
par la réalisation de bâtiments et des
moyens matériels correspondant
eurotunnel s'est immédiatement exécutés
compte tenu de l'urgence ces travaux ne
pouvaient pas satisfaire aux
autorisations d'urbanisme c'est pourquoi
par son ordonnance du 24 janvier 2019
le gouvernement a dispensé eurotunnel de
ces formalités pour procéder aux
aménagements demandé l'autorisation
était temporaire et la situation devait
encore être régularisés cette fois non
pas par ordonnance mais par une
disposition législative haddock destiné
à assurer la pérennité des
infrastructures
cette disposition législative c'est
l'article 24 du présent texte un article
un article triplement insatisfaisant
premièrement d'un point de vue formel sa
rédaction était clairement obscures
puisque le nom du code de référence à
savoir le code de l'urbanisme n'y
figurait pas je remercie notre
rapporteur cyril belva d'avoir corrigé
ce regretté
oubli deuxièmement sur le fond on ne
comprend pas si cet article valide
seulement les infrastructures déjà
réalisée par eurotunnel ou s'il conforte
a priori les aménagements qui devront
traiter encore fait si tel n'est pas le
cas faudra-t-il obtenir à chaque fois
une autorisation législative spécifiques
ce serait quand même kafkaïen non
l'article fait de plus pesé sur
eurotunnel une vraie insécurité aucun
aménagement liés à la sécurité à la
défense nationale à la sécurité civile
est ce nécessaire à son fonctionnement
ne sont possibles
croyez vous sincèrement que le tunnel ne
soient pas concernés
ils le sont au premier rang
troisièmement et de manière bien bien
plus fondamental le problème ponctuel du
break cité des aménagements douaniers
soulève la question du statut juridique
du tunnel sous la manche
le tunnel n'est à l'évidence pas une
simple ligne ferroviaire
cette infrastructure est exceptionnel il
serait temps de la considérer comme tel
des navettes transportent des camions
des voitures particulières des bus sur
une ligne bien prédéfinis pour mémoire
cet ouvrage sous la manche fut le plus
gros chantier du siècle dernier et il
assure une liaison
on parle d'écologie c'est une liaison
propres eurotunnel a besoin de sortir du
carcan du droit commun aujourd'hui
assimilé à une infrastructure
ferroviaire simple ses marges de
manoeuvre sont d'autant plus restreinte
qu'il ne figure pas aux exceptions de
l'article l 121 4 du code de l'urbanisme
contrairement aux ports et aux aveux et
eux aux aéroports pardon et c'est ce
qu'il faut changer
la question est quelle est notre
ambition pour cet ouvrage unique au
monde clé pour le développement national
est vitale à l'échelle locale
à nous d'y répondre aujourd'hui je
compte vraiment sur votre soutient
madame la ministre est notamment quand
je vous présenterai mes deux amendements
s'il vous plaît je vous remercie même si
la discussion générale est close et une
passons à la discussion du texte de la
commission
à l'article 1er je suis saisi d'un
amendement numéro 12 de monsieur de
vinasse merci suite